it's time kid
[Music]
welcome to your weekly tickets
shortly after its christmas day release
warner brothers announced it will fast
track a third installment of the wonder
woman franchise with patty jenkins set
to write and direct
gal gadot will also return to reprise
her role as wonder woman
in an interview with den of geek jenkins
revealed that wonder woman 3 will have a
contemporary setting
and tease that we might not have seen
the last of kristen wiig's cheetah
jenkins shared that she purposefully
left the fate of cheetah ambiguous at
the end of wonder woman 1984
but hasn't decided if she will return
for the third installment or not
channing tatum is in talks to join
sandra bullock in paramount's
action-packed romantic comedy titled the
lost city of d
the film is being described as a
romancing the stone style romantic
comedy which follows a reclusive romance
novelist played by bullock
who was sure nothing could be worse than
getting stuck on a book tour with her
cover model
played by tatum but when a kidnapping
attempt
sweeps them both into a cutthroat jungle
adventure they learn life can be so much
stranger and more romantic
than any of her paperback fictions and
tessa thompson just confirmed that
michael b jordan will be stepping behind
the camera to direct
creed 3. it will be jordan's directorial
debut taking the reins from ryan coogler
and stephen cable jr
who directed the first and second films
respectively jordan will also return to
reprise his role as boxer adonis creed
thompson who plays creed's love interest
bianca said filming is planning to start
this year
as we embark on 2021 you might be
looking for ways to keep your new year's
resolution
and what better way to start the year
than with some film recommendations to
not only inspire you to keep your new
year's resolution
but to help you make the best of the
next 12 months and here to keep us on
track
is film critic hannah flint hannah what
film should people watch
if they want to keep true to their new
year's resolutions
well i've got quite a few britney runs a
marathon this is an amazing directorial
debut for paul downs calazo and it
starts julian bell
and she plays a kind of millennial
slacker she likes to party
she drinks a bit too much eats a bit too
much and then she gets a shock to the
system when she finds out from her
doctors that
unless she loses a bit of weight and
gets healthier she could you know
pretty much die so that leads her to
start doing actual exercise
and obviously as you can tell by the
title there's marathon training there's
a marathon involved i won't spoil it
because i think you should go watch it
but what's really great about this film
is that not only is it funny but it
talks about the kind of small steps that
you have to make
not these massive you know math and oh
my god the idea of doing a marathon
that's quite insane quite a
big long goal it starts off with you
know just
putting on our trainers running to the
end of the road and then suddenly it
picks up and you get into this really
lovely kind of
i don't know motivational film that
feels real and relatable because she's
not this kind of you know stick thin
marathon runner who's doing it she
doesn't you know she loses a bit of
weight but not to the point where you're
like is that even julian bell anymore
yeah it's really quite sweet but also
gets the kind of emotional you know
truth of when you kind of do these plans
and how sometimes
it can get a bit much and can be intense
but making sure that you're doing things
for the right reasons so if it's just a
case of
you know you want to shake off the
pandemic get your running shoes back on
this is a really good film to watch to
make you feel good and make you feel
better
oh my god starting off strong with
running as a new year's resolution
what else you got my next film is
something
uh that i watched last year made me
realize that i definitely spend
too much money on random things i don't
really need
it is no ban land it's direct by closure
and stars francis mcdormand and it's a
kind of road trip movie about a nomad
who leaves her life
to find a new community and find new
purpose away from the world of consumers
culture
even though at one point she does end up
working at an amazon store
i think that's kind of a metaphor all
right um so what's your third movie
um so this is one of my favorite movies
it's like my
my parents my mom and dad they went on
their first date to see this movie field
of dreams
we're a big kevin costner fan club in my
house
we even let him off for water world but
field of dreams absolute classic 30
years old
you know i feel like just the basic you
know the whole
the whole thing that we all remember
from that film it's if you build it
it will come right he will come and i
think anyone who's wanting to start you
know
a craft project what's the i don't know
do you want to build your own baseball
field that might be something that's in
your future you might be an iowa farmer
who's like
looking to achieve something and so he
hears a voice and wants to build a
baseball field and
you know guess what people came you know
moral story
so if you put your mind to do something
you feel like you want to achieve
something and finish something and have
a kind of
emotional cathartic you know resolution
then yeah
if you build it you will come and watch
the field of dreams because it's
magnificent
and it's also got um james jones and we
absolutely
love james l jones my final film
uh is sliding doors the guinness paltrow
classic
i love this film because it kind of
imagines uh what this woman's pr girl in
london's
life would be like had she caught a
train or hadn't she not caught a train
in the version where she catches a train
she walks in on her boyfriend cheating
on her
and suddenly decides to change her life
she gets a haircut
a pixie cut blonde pixie cut she sets up
her npi agency
she finds new love yeah and she just
kind of has a much happier existence
because she's free from the kind of
restraints of being a
terrible loveless romance and in a job
that she hates but then in the other
version
she doesn't actually catch the train and
she's stuck in it for a long while and
it takes her ages to get to the point
where she realizes that yeah
her boyfriend is cheating on her her job
sucks she hates it
and you know it's just it wasn't worth
it she was ashamed she couldn't have
found that out in the first version she
didn't get that train but yeah i think
this is a great film to kind of push you
into you know getting out of bad
situations that are not serving you
you know don't stay in bad relationships
don't stay in a job that you hate
and don't feel like you need to say in
these things just because society says
that you should have
a husband by this age or the make
partner by that
age you know do what makes you happy and
if that means getting a blonde pixie cut
then go straight ahead all right so if i
got this right
you want me to build a baseball field uh
you want me to get a pixie cut and you
want me to
run a marathon yeah and all sounds good
i'm down
i'm down all right well thank you so
much hannah flint where can people find
you
find me on twitter at hannah flint
awesome well happy new year
happy new year
available to watch at home is american
dream
how much money you went to me for ed 126
that's 504 quarters
don't steal from me
american dream follows two brothers who
find themselves in serious trouble when
they're unable to repay a russian mob
backed
loan used to help fund their latest
entrepreneurial venture
but when the brothers are unable to pay
they're terrorized by yuri an unhinged
mobster who tortures and threatens them
and their loved ones
with death and taking over their
business the film is directed by
oscar-winning cinematographer yanus
kaminsky
and available to watch at home is fate
hall can you think of anyone who might
want to harm you
friends family
a woman you screwed
[Music]
after a wild one-night stand a
successful sports agent watches his
perfect life slowly disappear when he
discovers the sexy and mysterious woman
he risked
everything for is a police detective who
entangles him in her latest
investigation
as he desperately tries to put the
pieces together he falls deeper into her
trap
risking his family his career and his
own life
the film stars hilary swank michael ealy
and mike coulter
all right well that's it for today but
leave us a comment and let us know what
you'll be watching this week
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]